I was born
with the ability to see what people lack
in their hearts.
That's what I see in my eyes But
there's something missing in every plant Just like the
little girl had no sound
Every human being is always missing something There
's nothing I can do about what's missing So I can't help it
But I only know what's missing
Yuki
[music] Because
I
can't see it for myself
Yeah,
ah, ah, ah, ah,
2, what is it?
It's never fun to see things I mean, I
know how you feel
I used to be like that
You too I can see people's
death  In other words, it's the energy that is generated just before things that are regarded as life burns out
.  Enemy of the
world Even when spring comes, it brings coldness to the world The
snow that falls in April
Will you cooperate with my work Mr. Asukai,
what are
you talking about?
Inator Toyo Manmaze
[music]